where merrick garland was in the hot
seat the attorney general was grilled
over his doj memo targeting concerned
parents at school board meetings it all
started last month when the national
school board association sent a letter
to joe biden demanding action over what
they call
violence and intimidation at board
meetings across the country but
listen to this new reporting reveals
that the nsba had quote collaborated
with the biden white house before
sending a controversial letter calling
on the fbi to investigate parents
as potential domestic terrorists
so
was the biden administration colluding
with the national school board
association did the white house
weaponize the doj to label parents all
across this great nation
as domestic terrorists
the answers to those questions seem to
be unequivocally
yes
because the justice department then
quickly followed the nsba's lead and
issued a memo saying they would identify
and prosecute these domestic threats
but how did the doj reach that
conclusion did they do some type of
in-depth research did they conduct a
nationwide investigation do they have
specific threats
congressman jim jordan wanted to find
out
when did you first review the data
showing this so-called disturbing uptick
so i read the letter and we have been
seeing over time
threats whoa whoa i didn't ask you so
you read the letter that's that's your
source so let me be clear
this is not a prosecution or is there
some study some effort some
investigation someone did that said
there's been a disturbing uptick or you
just take the words of the national
school board association
nothing
nothing more than a letter garland
wouldn't give a straight answer but he
gave nothing more than a letter as the
predicate for this investigation and by
the way congressman jordan was cut off
before he could press anymore but it's
obvious that the white house was
following the nsba's lead and the doj
was following the white house's lead
and that is not the only concern
congress had with the attorney general
louisiana congressman mike johnson took
the ag to task for his family's business
ties to critical race theory
it also concerns us that your actions
may have been motivated by your family's
financial stake in this issue published
reports so that show that your
son-in-law co-founded a company called
panorama education we now know that that
company publishes and sells critical
race theory and so-called anti-racism
materials to schools across the country
did you seek ethics counsel before you
issued a letter that directly relates to
the financial interest of your family
yes or no this memorandum does not
relate to the financial interests of
anyone it's a thr it's again i take that
as a no
to be clear the attorney general's
son-in-law sells critical race theory
processes and products to more than 23
thousand school districts schools across
this country
if that's not being compromised i don't
know what is
so the white house the doj all
compromised in their connections with
both the national school board
association and with critical race
theory and yet they continue to push on
targeting concerned parents
so look why is this so important well
here's one real world consequence
to what's inside that letter
one of the people the nsba targeted as a
domestic terrorist is a father from
loudoun county virginia why
because he showed up to protest at a
school board meeting that parent's name
is scott smith and as you can see here
he was pinned down by police and
arrested during a school board meeting
in june
now smith
wanted accountability from the school
board after their transgender policies
led to his teenage daughter being
allegedly raped
in the school bathroom
by a man in a skirt
obviously a harrowing experience no
parent should have to deal with and
every parent
would want to find accountability on
but instead of doing anything to help
smith to allay his concerns the bite
administration is looking to vilify him
and hundreds of other parents as
domestic terrorists
luckily congressman chip roy of texas
would not let garland get away with this
the girl who had been raped sodomized in
the bathroom of a high school by a dude
wearing a skirt that father reacted this
man this arrest of a 48 year old plumber
became the poster boy for the new
domestic terrorism the biden
administration the administration in
which you serve
has concocted to destroy anyone who gets
in the way do you believe that a father
attending a meeting exercising his first
amendment rights and yes getting angry
about whatever lies are being told about
his daughter being raped in the school
he sent her to be educated in that this
is domestic terrorism yes or no
no i do not think that parents getting
angry at school boards for whatever
reason constitute domestic terrorism
so then
why did you send that letter mr attorney
general
why did you issue that memo
why target parents across this country
who are only concerned with their
children's safety their education and
their future hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else